[Applause]
[Music]
I have this avocado gadget it slices it
with this it hits it and then you can
slice it with this thing I'm literally
just using a knife because I don't need
I'll just try to open avocados
the test date we're gonna see who can
cut three avocados the fastest really
what do you do when you get sneeze
[Music]
the cutting part was easy taking the pit
out was easy but as you can see the
slicing part is not easy nor pretty up
next we are hard boiling some eggs and I
am using this rapid egg cooker and I'm
just using a good old pot of boiling
water so to use this little guy you have
to first fill it up with the amount of
water that you want so we want
hard-boiled egg so I filled it up to the
top pour the water in there but a key
step is making sure that you put little
tiny holes in the top of the egg and
there's a little puncher on the bottom
[Music]
they both made good eggs but I think
this has a built-in timer you literally
put the eggs on it don't have to worry
about it yeah and I think like
considering the time you have to wait to
boil water this actually would be faster
so I think for this round kala you one
next we're going to be taking corn off
of the cob and I have this corn stripper
which is going to just literally take
the corn off so I'm gonna be using this
Kerry knife and I'm gonna be making four
cuts to take the corn off instead of
using that mouse
[Music]
I struggled and I think part of the
reason why was this wasn't as sharp as I
thought it was gonna be a lot of it was
falling out on the cutting boards so
yeah that one just didn't work I am
using the earth scissors and shocker I
am using this knife
[Music]
[Music]
so for this is around I think it's
actually a tie Halo one with the green
onions
wait wait wait can you say that one more
time yellow one and I think I won with
the parsley I am going to use this
microwave pasta boat to use this
microwave pasta boats you first want to
measure out your pasta and they have
this cool thing the handle that measures
- serving size of the pasta I filled it
up to the to mark because I have two
servings okay we're good I cook all the
way through oh yeah and it's like al
dente like I'd prefer to eat this one
yeah all right
pasta boat who knew
I guess that means we tied today hi I
honestly thought I was gonna lose I
honestly thought I was gonna win
[Music]